brother man this is joey donuts calling
from manhattan
joey don is baby from manhattan
them sugar circles baby
blessing us baby
with them glucose o's baby donuts dog
from the big s from the big city baby up
there in big apple country
big apple baby gang dominicans
so i've got a big date lined up in a few
days
we've got a couple mutual friends
we went to the same school
but you know i barely know this chica
i just wanted some advice you know what
do you talk about what should i say
first date i'm a little nervous
let me know what's going on brother man
gang baby i appreciate the question
there
and sorry to cut you off man but
i can and uh
and
here's the first date move here's the
first date move you take the lady to a
uh
maternity ward
take her to the local hospital
i used to do this move when i was a
child pre-teen or teen you know
as soon as i was uh
you know viral or whatever sexually
mature
as they called it in science or
pre-science i don't know what we took
but i gotta be
but um
as soon as you're sexually mature and
you have a date
you should take her to the infirmary or
uh
maternity ward
here's what i would do i would take the
because we didn't have a lot of
attractions in our area
you know you could see maybe there had
been a fire you could go over there
you could park by the water
you know which is fun but
it just
it leaves
the other people coming apart by the
water usually deviant
you know somebody out there smoking a
pill or
uh people that want to have sex outdoors
and when you're still a youngster
you want to take her somewhere
that's at least
decently lit
you know so her parents don't get upset
so what i found was the maternity ward
you take her in there because you see
that the babies are in there
and you show a girl the baby you sh that
that tells her right there a
you're a family man
you're about that life
okay you're about life you're about i
mean you're looking at actual because
the window's there the babies are in
there they got them in there you know in
the little
uh
you know vestibules or whatever
so you get to see each one in the little
carton and um
beer so you're about actual life
you're about
life
so you're showing her that
and she knows you're about sex because a
baby
you didn't get a baby without sex
you know that happened one time in the
desert
and that's that that's a
that's a wrap
but since then it's taken a couple of
people
you know
touching
doing touch
so
so you let her know about sex you take
her dinner no there's no sex and
nobody's
nobody's [ __ ] in the back so you can
eat
at the applebee
you know there's not you know
there's not two people back there
fornicating
over there at the captain d seafood or
whatever so you guys can have a you know
can do a um
a shrimp shrimp you know basket
so but if you show her that baby it puts
it there's a thing that happens
where it just shows hey i know about sex
i'm sexually mature that's what it does
it lets a woman know you know about sex
you take her to dinner i don't mean you
know about sex
that means you know about recipes you
know about silverware
you know about uh
you know
being indoors or whatever but you take
her to the
s to the maternity bam
she sees that and some of the babies
this still smell like sex in there
you know the one in our town the window
was
was uh busted between the
babies and the um visitor
so you're sitting there you know what
i'm saying i think they even had a
little broken glass around there but
um
yes you could still smell i mean you
still get that hit
and some of the babies they really they
definitely smell like uh some of them
smell like doggy style some one of them
you'll see still have a panty wrapped
around his wrist there's some real
you know them italian ones there's some
real
it gets a little hype
so
that's your first day to answer brother
what are you going to take her to wear
dave and buster's take her to bust and
busters
you know what i'm saying
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you